all right mark why don't you starters
okay we'll take questions in room
uh malika in the middle just wait for
the microphone please on
two two we'll get her go ahead
bam hello bam
you were so hard on yourself after game
five and looking ahead to the lakers
they are such a big
team which makes your role which makes
kelly olynyk's role even more important
how do you approach especially the early
minutes looking towards this matchup to
kind of avoid getting in
ticky tack foul trouble early what do
you see your role as here
uh obviously you gotta be smart about
you know like you said ticket taking
foul but uh
being active you know just match their
energy
you know there there can't be a second
on the floor where they're playing part
of this
you know i feel like that's that's where
our chances
you know we just can't we can't let them
just get free layups and getting his
motion
and then you know that's when
everything starts clicking for him so
just making it tough for him and then
also uh
being smart with the basketball and then
just setting up strategic plays to get
like easy basses
tim reynolds right here on the right
side
you've probably been through like 700
practices with this team in three years
was
did today have any sort of a different
feel as far as it being a finals
practice or was it
just a typical heat get down to work day
yeah it's preparation
you know we've been prepping for this
since
september which is kind of crazy but uh
you know uh if we would have been
preparing for the finals
two weeks ago we wouldn't be ready you
know this has been like a grind
throughout this whole year just shaving
and morphing and uh
trying to figure this out and now we're
here so
you know toss up now
next question will manso hey bam
uh spo was almost defensive earlier in
the postseason when someone kept asking
people kept asking about your style of
play and whether you should be more
aggressive and he said look i'm a bands
bam stop trying to make up something
else
but there's no doubt that your numbers
have gone up significantly in the
playoffs from all-star level almost
superstar level i mean what
what do you attribute that to what has
been the difference you think in your
production
uh
don't know um you know to me i feel like
i'm out there hooping and just doing the
right things
and uh making the right plays and uh
just holding myself accountable you know
we're in the playoffs
it's uh
this is winner go home so you know when
you have that type of
that type of mindset you got to go out
there and back that up
and uh i've been doing that and i need
to keep doing that
next question ethan scully bam um
both anthony davis and dwight howard
have been very complimentary
of you as a player um and kind of
watching you
dwight dwight went on for about three
minutes when he was in miami uh when the
lakers came in about how much he just
enjoys your style of play
uh what is the challenge for you against
both of these players because you're
going to be seeing i'm sure
a lot of both before the series is over
with uh
they're shot blockers you know that's
that's that's one thing that they're
gifted with
shot blocking so just uh
not letting them off the hook just stand
just staying aggressive and then uh
get my teammates open and just keep
playing my style of basketball
dave right here on the right side in
person bam staying on that same line of
questioning
jimmy and lebron are going to get a lot
of the attention going into this thing
but
it serious could hinge on the mattress
between you and anthony davis
and how do you you view that and then
also going back to the
kentucky connection do you guys have any
sort of a poor relationship through that
uh i mean
unless you go to kentucky you'll follow
it forever so
you know me going into kentucky and come
in he probably heard about me didn't
know who i was probably
just a kid going to kentucky but uh
you know you never know this city is
going to be fun man like you said it
might be me a.d
it might be lebron and jimmy so at the
end of the day
we're just gonna go out there and just
play like we've been playing throughout
the series
and put together a 48 minutes of miami
basketball or even longer if we have to
in person dan over here
um you've been wearing the kobe
5s throughout these playoffs you wore
them in the in the
the last game i know um his death this
year how did it affect you
and when you wear those shoes do you
spend any time kind of thinking about
what he's meant
to you or the game oh well obviously you
you you know what he means to the game
because you've seen everybody when they
heard about it
nobody wanted to believe that i it still
doesn't feel real
to this day but uh you see the effect
that he had on the world
and uh me growing up i was a kobe fan
kobe fanatic and uh just getting
just being able to just wear his shoes
and uh
you know it's my favorite shoe to play
so
i've been planting them uh this whole
playoff run
so can't stop now
all right our last question for bam is
from kyle tucker the athletic
curious what's one specific thing from
your time at kentucky that you think
most prepared you to have this kind of
success this early
on this big of a stage in the nba um
in kentucky when when you play against
rival schools
it's kind of like they're they're super
bowl
so whoever we play away or at home
they're going to give us our best game
because they want to beat it so bad so
you can't be scared to be in those
moments that define you define your team
you can't be scared to live
live up for those moments i feel like
that's the biggest thing that
helped me get to where i am living in
those moments
thank you ma'am black lives matter
people
thank you young fella jimmy will be
right up
oh hey jimmy butler man what's up man
we'll take questions in person for jimmy
tim reynolds here on the right side see
jimmy you're um i i don't want to say
your mo because it does vary from game
to game but you're very big on getting
your teammates involved early even some
games like pointing to the corner
telling duncan go there and
expect the ball and all those things do
you expect
that to be the way you're going to start
the finals as well or do you have to
look to get
you have to kind of go out of character
to get yours a little bit too and get
yourself
get yourself going a little uh i don't
know you know we'll
we'll see as the game goes but
i think there's there's a lot of nerves
for a lot of people
including myself this is the first time
being here so i just want to make sure
that everybody's comfortable
and we've been playing a certain way
this entire year
i'm not getting away from that i think
that's winning basketball for us
me making sure that everybody's involved
i think that's a
part of my role on this team so we'll
take it as
the game goes and then we'll we'll
figure it out but i mean
i'm sure before the game um
ud dre spoke
they'll definitely tell me what to look
for and
how to start i guess
next question david aldridge jimmy
um wondering if the year you've spent
down there
getting to know uh riles and and what
he's about
matches what you may have thought about
him before you got there
yep every uh aspect of it
everything that i've heard obviously
from from d wade
and just around the league it's
everything that i wanted to be a part of
he's the individual outside of
basketball that everybody's
said that he uh that he was and i'm
definitely about
winning and winning now he's definitely
about that so
he's been a huge part in our success of
putting this team together
expecting greatness out of each and
every one of us and putting us in a
position to be great
so without him without him putting this
thing together
i wouldn't be up here everyone had his
great group of guys that we have so we
are all very thankful
for the godfather next question tom
deangelo
give me uh when you enter the league
lebron was 26
how how much is he much of a different
player now with 35 and how
how impressive is it that he's been able
to play at this level at 35.
uh he's still at the top of his game at
35
at 26 at 21. he's still dominating
and i mean you've had to go through him
at 26
35 probably at 49
but he's shown why he is the player that
he is why he's had the career and the
legacy that he's continually building
um and it's not going to be an easy task
these next couple of games
if anybody's up for that task the miami
heat on
in person here dave jimmy uh obviously
your decision to go to miami seems to be
paying off
um splendidly so far but last summer
there were a handful of teams with the
cap space to be able to accommodate a
player
of your ilk and i wanted to know if
there was any consideration on your part
about seeing what the lakers had to
offer uh or going down that road at all
no i i knew um
the type of structure that i wanted and
needed and it was here
heard about it obviously whenever i was
meeting with coach paul coach pat
it just it just felt right in every
aspect of it
how there's just we got a bunch of good
people here not saying this lakers don't
got a great
bunch of uh people but um everything
they're about it just fit me working
we got a group of guys that do that as
well you know
saying it like it is holding everybody
accountable
and moving on from it you know they say
that that's that's how we do that you
get to come here you get to be
you i'm in
next question is vincent goodwill
jimmy i know your time in chicago didn't
end the way that you liked but how much
time have you spent thinking about some
of your old teammates the lewaldings the
taj gibsons
the joe kim knows the guys who haven't
made it to this level
have you spent any time with reflection
thinking about that early part of your
journey
uh i mean uh i'm grateful for that part
of my journey and for those guys
um they showed me the way to being a pro
they showed me um where hard work will
get you
and how you just can never give up i
talk to a lot of those guys still
and i let them know how thankful that i
am because i don't think that i'd be
here without them
them letting me know that you have to
stay ready your time is coming
and that you belong here they were
constantly telling me how
i could play in this league for a very
long time so looking back on it
i guess i could say um a part of the
reason i'm here is because of those guys
malika in the center jimmy you said the
other day that you
don't like to be thought of as underdogs
because you're a group of
nba players but you did have 60 to one
odds to
to be here what is the identity that you
you do like to think of yourselves as if
it isn't underdogs
a really good team that's it a really
good team
uh not gonna say that uh we're any
better than anybody else but
i just don't think that we're underdogs
i don't
so what that nobody picked us to be here
um
that's okay pretty sure nobody's picking
us to win either
that's okay um but we understand that we
embrace that
because at the end of the day we truly
don't care we just gonna go out here and
compete
play together like we always have and
i'm see where we end up but at the end
of the day
we're gonna do this our way the miami
heat way and um that way it's worked for
us all year long
next question greg logan jimmy i'd like
to ask you to go a little
deeper on what you said earlier about
going to miami because you like the
structure there
because you were with a very talented
team in philadelphia
and it didn't click what is it about
this organization or this structure
that fit you so well and that allowed
you to make
the act that you did um
i think i like i said i just get to to
be
me here um i get to call it how i see it
nobody takes it personally you have to
worry about anybody trying to control me
um as it was said people was trying to
do over there
but i have no hard feelings towards any
of those players
anybody in that organization i'm glad to
be where i am
as you can tell it's worked out
and and that's where i leave it i knew
what we could do
here we added some key pieces in the
middle of the year
and um we are where we are so i don't
really look back at it too much
i got to stay focused in on the right
now and with the group that i have
do gary on your left before we go back
to rob on zoom hey jimmy
for your career you've just been
yourself and you've ruffled some
feathers and that type of thing was
there ever a point
in your career you thought am i doing
this right or was it just
like you said just finding the right
place that would welcome you
right by who like everybody gonna have
their own opinion
nobody's in the locker room nobody's at
the practices
it's all he said she said to a point
so nobody really knows what's really
going on i don't explain anything
detailed for detail um so i just take
being a bad guy i like it that way so
like
it doesn't bother me it's not like i'm
reading everything that's on the
internet
i know who i am i'm cool i'm content
with that
um and that's what i leave it at you
know i'm here now
and i belong here i
belong here for a very long time
so that that that's where i'm at here me
being
ruffling feathers whatever you want to
call it it's okay here
next question krista saltes hello jimmy
you talk about the heatway so which
what will gonna be the key factors of
the whole series for you
and also if you win the championship you
will you bring a free coffee from your
coffee shop to your teammates
i'm not giving nobody free coffee ever
it's just it's not gonna happen except
for coach oh
coach oh he gets free coffee um
and then um as far as the first question
i just think um a championship is
is gonna be one that we have to do
together and i can't exactly remember
how you worded the question
so i'm just gonna guess um
but i know that together this group
it's it's how we want to win it i think
we enjoy
each other's success so much man that
you can tell every single day when we're
in the hotel
you know yeah we talk about the game but
we also talk about
how much joy it brings us to play with
one another and how you can't take this
for granted
and when uh with this group you know we
got the right number of young guys who
are
super confident older guys who are super
confident then guys that are right in
the middle they're super confident so
um for us it brings us pure joy
to uh watch us continually grow as a
team
all right the last question that we will
take on the zoom will be brandon tobin
hey jimmy there was a great video of
your guys celebration of you walking in
wearing an eric exposure university of
portland jersey
how did you get your hands on that and
no what did he say when he saw it on you
uh obviously he thought it was comical
but i got a i got quite a few jerseys
tucked away in my room
it's just when is the right time to pull
them out
but you know spo has been huge for me
and my growth here
as a player as a leader
as a human being so i'm grateful for him
but you know just to keep it
lighthearted and
enjoy a win knowing
the most difficult part is ahead of us
so i know it's just a way to show my
appreciation
last question here sam jimmy you talk
about pat
with such reverence but i'm curious if
you go back to
the pre-heat days and even maybe when
you're a youngster like when did pat
riley
become a person who you were aware of
and then when you went through free
agency
you've talked about the meeting but i
mean did you talk to dude about pat did
you talk to lebron about pat i mean
how did you learn about him i mean i i
played with d-wade and i think that's
that's where the whole thing started
yeah you know who pat riley is
but it's not like you're going in in
detail
um because obviously i thought i was
going to be in chicago my entire career
but he he would tell me about the way
things were done there
about coach bo about coach pat
and then it's man that's that's my type
of guy that i want to play for that i
want to be around
obviously i get traded a couple times
and end up here
and it's everything i'm i'm so
comfortable
um with being myself more than i've ever
been not saying i've ever not wanted to
be myself
but now i know myself is the right way
look where myself has have gotten me now
and it's all because he empowered me to
be able to do that
with these guys these guys
love me love who i am and it's
reciprocated towards those guys
um i'm just grateful for him and for him
believing in me and giving me this
opportunity
thank you jimmy thanks jimmy